wir haben es geschafft wir haben es
geschafft unser wahlziel zu erreichen
wir sind mit abstand die stärkste partei
sie haben uns neu zu stärksten
politischen kraft gemacht die
landtagswahlen in baden-württemberg und
rheinland-pfalz haben drei lehrern
gebracht die erste ist nach einem jahr
corona und corona krise ist dass
politische parteien system nicht
umgepflügt worden sondern kontinuität
steht am ende dieser beiden
landtagswahlen die bisher schon
erfolgreichen ministerpräsidenten
winfried kretschmann und malu dreyer
sind auch weiterhin erfolgreich und von
den wählern bestätigt worden
man sieht aber auch dass die afd die
doch mit sehr provokativen vorschlägen
in der korona krise nach vorne kam schon
verloren hat aber auch sich etablieren
konnte auch in einem sehr wohlhabenden
bundesland wie baden württemberg und
trotz dessen dass sie vom
verfassungsschutz jetzt für möglich als
beobachtungs fall als
rechtsextremistischer beobachtungs fall
eingestuft wird
die zweite große lehre dieses abends ist
dass es der cdu nicht gut geht sie hat
in beiden ländern deutlich verloren es
war mit keinem großen erfolg zu rechnen
aber ihr ergebnis ist noch schlechter
als erwartet wir hätten uns bei den
landtagswahlen in baden-württemberg und
rheinland-pfalz andere werden uns
bessere ergebnisse gewünscht
woran liegt das gleich an mehreren
gründen zum einen war es für die cdu
schwierig gegen sehr charismatische
erfolgreiche ministerpräsidenten
anzukommen
vor allen dingen winfried kretschmann
ist sehr gut darin dass eigentlich
konservative klientel in baden
württemberg anzusprechen und von der cdu
wegzulocken das ist die nun schon seit
vielen jahren sehr gelungen und die cdu
hat kein rezept dagegen auch in
rheinland pfalz gibt es eine prominente
und charismatische ministerpräsidentin
gegen die die cdu einfach kein rezept
hatte
außerdem stellt die cdu sich gerade aber
auch selbst ein bein
die masken affäre belastet die partei
schwer führende politiker bemühen sich
sehr um aufklärung aber noch ist unklar
wie sehr das die fraktion und die partei
nach unten reißen wird sowieso hat es
die union gerade ziemlich schwer sie
wird nicht wieder mit der sehr populären
an
merkel antreten und nun wird schon
versucht allen möglichen schaden vom
neuen parteivorsitzenden armin laschet
abzuwenden
es ist noch vollkommen offen ob das
gelingen wird auch im bund zeigen die
umfragewerte der union deutlich nach
unten
die dritte lehre ist mit den grünen ist
absolut zu rechnen sie haben ihren
positiven trend der schon seit vielen
monaten zu beobachten ist verstetigt es
ist für uns ein super start ins
superwahljahr und wir werden dem
rückenwind aus baden württemberg und
rheinland pfalz dann hoffentlich mit
vollen segeln aufnehmen können dann in
den monat nächsten monaten die da kommen
weiter fahrt aufnehmen die dynamik nach
vorne treiben und nach vorne treiben
winfried kretschmann ist der
erfolgreichste grüne den die partei
vielleicht je hatte er ist aber auch ein
sehr unbequemes parteimitglied und für
die parteiführung in berlin stellt sich
also jetzt die frage wie wollen sie in
dieses war ja gehen welches
politikangebot wollen sie dem wähler
machen einen sehr pragmatischen nah am
bürger orientierten kretschmann stil
oder wollen sie eher wie der klassische
grüne themen nach vorne stellen
das wird dann entscheidend dafür sein
welchen erfolg die grünen bei der
bundestagswahl erreichen werden